hey there outlander fans i'm liana
giller from entertainment tonight and
i'm joined i'm seeing ian double right
now because i've got stephen cree and
john bell who play ian murray and
younger ian murray thank you guys so
much for welcoming me into lolly brock
thank you
what has it been like for you john to
enter the outlander world incredible it
has been i'm only just started as well i
have so much to go in this world that i
just can't wait to get it all i love
that well and of course this is steven
he's playing your father on the show how
have you guys been getting that
father-son connection off-screen so that
it'll show on screen i've been punishing
john
on a daily basis yeah and giving giving
him a little bit of pocket money oh
that's nice you know john is just fitted
in seamlessly from day one john is
extremely
uh confident and um professional and
it was um and he paid me to say all of
that
but no it must be really fun for you to
come into the outlander world because
they have a pretty passionate fan base
and ian young anne has a really
significant part in voyager what can you
tease for the fans out there i think
what you're going to see from young ian
is a real change in season three
from this gawky scottish teenager to his
own man steven we're going to be
catching up with ian 20 years later what
can you fill in for the fans and tease
as to what he uh and his wife have been
up to lots of
sex
because they have so many kids now they
have a lot of kids
ian looks at jenny and she gets pregnant
i think
um so there's plenty of that you get a
bit more of a glimpse into ian's
relationship with jenny and what is you
know how he
how seriously he takes fatherhood
and obviously you know more of his
friendship with uh with jamie as well
well i was gonna say how do we see uh
ian and jamie's brother-in-law bond
strengthened throughout voyager
you know they've got such a
an unbreakable bond from everything that
they've gone through and ian
there's a kind of like in a way
ian will love and stand by jaime i think
no matter what but also you know jamie's
uh still reckless and ian is safer uh i
think in his old days so you also see
some of that conflict
between them as well you know but always
a respect yeah is there anything that
you've learned from stephen and from sam
that's made you feel like a better actor
yes
yes every guy on the
yes absolutely nothing comes to mind at
the moment but yes
i'm just kidding
and for all the latest on outlander be
sure to follow them on twitter instagram
and facebook
[Music]
[Music]
you